نبحث في كافه السبل للقيام بذلك دون تعريض
مواطنين للخطر
السيد الرئيس ان وقفه لقناه ليس مقدمه
بالضروره للسلام والوضع يمكن ان يتفاقم في
الايام المقبله سنواصل دعم الرعايه
البريطانيه لذلك قمنا بانشاء تواجد في
بورتسودان ولدينا مسؤولين دبلوماسيون في
مصر واثيوبيا والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
السيد الرئيس السودان هو ثالث اكبر بلد
افريقي
ويبعد حول 800 ميل من بين العاصمه واسوان
في مصر
وخمسمائه بين الخرطوم والبحر الاحمر حتى
في ظل انعدام
الحرب فان هناك الكثير من التحديات ندرك
الكثير من الرعايه البريطانيين غادروا
والسودان بوسائل اخرى
بعضهم استطاعوا ان يستفيدوا من اجلاء الذي
تقوم به دول شريكه
نحن نعمل على مهامنا الدبلوماسيه
لتقديم المساعدات القنصليه السيد الرئيس
نقوم ببذل كل الجهود لاجلاء رعينا في
السودان هو هدف اساسي ندعو الجانبين لوقفه
قتل لمصلحه السوداني لدى عنه ما يكفي خلال
عقود من الحرب الاهليه نبحث كل السبل لخفض
الصعيد وزير الدفاع وزير التنميه
هو ان على اتصال مباشر مع شركائنا
الدوليين دور الاتحاد الافريقي وكذلك
منظمات وشركائنا في المنطقه والخليج
وخارجها سيكون حاسما السيد الرئيس المملكه
المتحده لديها علاقات تعميقه مع الشعب
السوداني نحن تضامن معه وندعم حقه في
الحصول على المستقبل ديموقراطي وللعوده
الى الحكم المدني المملكه المتحده
جهود دوليه لاعاده بناء الاقتصاد السوداني
ووقف المعنات لكن المهمه ليست سهله غير
انها حيويه
للاقليم
والسودانيين سنواصل القيام بذلك وسنجلي
رعينا لاماكن امنه وسنعمل ايضا على اعاده
اعمار هذا البلد العظيم شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات